[موسيقى]
احتفل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن مع رئيس
اي وزراء بريطانيا واستراليا باتفاق اوكوس
على منصه فييجو وتظهر في الخلفيه غواصه من
نوع فرجينيا ستتسلى مثيلاتها استراليا
بنهايه العقد
اريد ان اكون واضحا منذ البدايه فلا يكون
هناك اللغط او سوء فهم فهذه النقطه مفصليه
الغواصات تسير بالقوه النوويه وليست مسلحه
نوويا مسيره وليست مسلحه نوويا
شدد الرئيس الامريكي كثيرا على هذه الميزه
في محاوله للتاكيد ان الولايات المتحده لا
تسعى مع استراليا الى تهديد الدول في
المحيط الهادئ خصوصا الصين
اتفاق اوكسو الذي نؤكده هنا في سانديجو
يمثل اكبر استثمار في امكانيات استراليا
العسكريه في تاريخ بلادنا
ويشمل الاتفاق الذي اعلن عنه بدايه
التعاون بين البحريه الامريكيه
والاستراليه في مجال الغواصات المسيره على
القوات النوويه ثم تسليم استراليا ثلاث
غواصات امريكيه على ان تتعاون بريطانيا
والولايات المتحده في بناء غواصات بصناعه
استراليه
تزيد الغواصات والسفن المسيره بالطاقه
النوويه من مسافه الابحار وهذا يعني
الابتعاد عن شواطئ استراليا والاقتراب من
شواطئ الصين ومن الخطوط البحريه الصينيه
الى الشرق الاوسط من حيث يستوردون الطاقه
جاء اتفاق اوكوس على حساب فرنسا اولا لان
استراليا تخلت عن شراء الغواصات الفرنسيه
كما يبدو الاتفاق تهيئه لمواجهه المحاولات
الصينيه للتوسع في المحيط الهادئ رئيس
وزراء بريطانيا لم يتردد في الحديث عن
المخاطر
في الاشهر الثمانيه عشر الماضي يتصاعدت
التحديات التي واجهناها من اجتياح روسيا
لاوكرانيا الى التصرفات الصينيه
والاضطرابات التي تسببت بها ايران وكوريا
الشماليه وكلها تهدد العالم بالمخاطر
والاضطرابات والانقسام يبدو هذا الاتفاق
على انه تاهيل واضح للقوه العسكريه
الاستراليه بدعما من الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وايا كانت التبريرات فهذا
التاهيل العسكري لاستراليا يبدو موجها ضد
الصين العربيه